hello kind sir my name is sean spencer
this is my partner bert interhand and
bush my name is not berdindahan and bush
my name is burton guster and this is my
partner potential spam i'll call later
[Music]
you're calling kurt smith
he's not gonna play your wedding dude i
haven't decided yet gusta yes you have
have you learned song song yet
hello
today is all about gus and his
soon-to-be wife who's leading a double
life that has something to do with that
gun we found also we finally are on to
the husband she's married try and keep
up gus is losing hope and feeling
slightly incontinent most of that is
true
what is her name you don't know your
fiance's name not her real one no it's
not prince is it ignore him it's not
prince is it
how old do you think we are younger than
james bader when he did pretty in pink
and mccarthy
will you kindly suck you're sucking you
suck you suck you flame suck it how dare
you
i'm back drink it in gee this is a big
deal how fast can we drive as fast as we
want
[Music]
i'll be honest i didn't think we'd have
to take our pants off for this i didn't
ask you to
well observed
do you have the peacock what's that it's
a streaming service ah there's so many
streamers you know she's talking no
she's making that up
[Music]
you